Well, uh, good afternoon,
everyone. Welcome to day 4.
Can't believe it.
How are we doing, surviving?
Yes, good.
Well, you made it to day 4, and I'm
super excited that you've decided to join
me for the next 45 minutes or
so attending this session.
This is 314.
My name is Shayan Sanyal. I'm a principal
Database Specialist at AWS.
Today, we are going to dive deep into
how to build surless chatbots using
Elasticash and Aurora posters.
Who's using Arre in production today? Just
a show of hands.
Oh, majority of you, OK.
And who's building chatbots using apostress
as the database?
No one. OK. Well, you're in the right
room. So let's dive in.
So our case study today is
flightly. It's a fictitious
travel platform that allows customers
to search flights,
book hotels, and plan vacations.
Today we'll crack open the architecture. We'll
help slightly build it.
And we'll sort of also see how to evolve
this basic chatbot that Flightly has
into an agentic AI system.
Along the way, we are extracting some
reusable architecture patterns that hopefully
you can apply in your own systems.
Let's dive in.
Friday afternoon,
I'm planning a vacation to Hawaii.
I type my query in slightly, and
it starts thinking.
Still thinking, still thinking, still going.
So I do what we all do.
I go and check my email.
And very quickly I'll notice that this
Island Air competitor has a flash sale.
Hawaii flights, ironically, great
price.
Back to flight Lee, still thinking.
I book with Island Air.
Done. Flight Lee
just lost me as a customer.
And probably thousands of others,
not because the product was bad,
but the chat was just too slow.
Let me show you what this costs the business.
30 seconds average response time
for a single booking.
About half of their users hit this
performance wall.
Average booking value is about 300
bucks. They handle a million
requests daily.
Now, industry data shows that
every second of delay
costs you 7% in conversions.
With super long response times,
even a tiny fraction of users abandoning
adds up very quickly.
So, if you just do the math, it's about $1500
lost every day,
which compounds to $50 million
annually. So
how do we fix this?
Here's the thing
When Flightly started, they didn't see
this coming.
They hoped they were building for speed and scale
like everyone does,
but the team did what most of us would
do. They built an MVP. They started quick,
launched the platform, user adoption accelerated.
But success created new problems.
Thousands of users became millions,
and suddenly they are hitting this entirely
new set of bottlenecks
that obviously doesn't appear unless you're at this scale.
So the question kind of shifted.
How do you maintain sub-second response
times
when you're processing millions of requests per
day? Here's
what Flightly's working with.
Customer data and company data.
It's similar data to what we all have
in our databases.
Customer data includes things such as past
bookings, search history, preferences, etc.
Company data is flight inventory,
hotel inventory, promotions, etc.
All of this data lives in Aurora Press.
Years and years of rich data.
Perfect foundation for a chatbot.
But here's the problem,
without a cache, every query hits the
database.
Every semantic search recomutes vector
distances.
At a million requests per day,
you get exactly what we saw,
painful response times.
Now, your instinct might be, let's
migrate to a faster database.
But that includes new infrastructure,
new ETL pipelines, migration risk.
And Aurora's been rock solid for years.
The database isn't the problem, it's the
access pattern.
So we keep Aurora as our source of truth
and add a caching layer. Let's
keep that in mind.
Let's understand the current architecture.
User query comes in, find me a beach resort
in Bali.
The system queries Aurora as a knowledge
base.
It pulls relevant context, things such
as availability, seasonal pricing,
and the user's preferences.
All of this gets assembled into a context
aware system prompt.
Which is nothing but the instructions set
for the LLM.
The system prompt does 2 things.
It defines behavior, so answer
travel questions, reference the knowledge base,
maintain conversation history,
and it sets personality.
Be warm, enthusiastic, helpful.
This enriched prompt plus the user's
question gets sent to a large language model.
Which then generates a tailored
response. Now, for
a single turn conversation,
single interaction, single user asking
this question,
This architecture works great. This is perfect.
But watch what happens when
we scale this to thousands of users
concurrently asking the same questions
or different questions.
So now we have multiple users
hitting the system.
And in travel,
I like to think of it as the potato rule. It's
80% of your queries are
just different questions,
uh, are just 20 questions wearing different
outfits.
Now watch the latencies stack up. The orange
lines are your warning zones.
The red lines are now we are hitting the limits of
the system. Every
single query triggers the exact
same expensive pipeline.
Your query hits your database, there is a distance
calculation,
fetches context,
assembles the system prompt, and sends it
to the LLM.
Each operation adds about 100 milliseconds,
and that stacks up.
You'll notice very quickly,
you're spending over a 0 2nd,
over 500 milliseconds per
request. And this keeps getting
worse.
Response times start degrading from 500
milliseconds to 5 seconds to 30
seconds. At a million users
daily,
this architecture is unsustainable.
Ask your application teams what's wrong and I'm sure
they'll all point straight to the database.
But it's not the database's fault, it's the
access pattern. All right.
We touched on caching a little bit earlier.
Let's dig into why it's essential for
conversational AI at scale.
When a user asks about baggage policies,
frequently asked questions,
a cache can serve that in under a millisecond.
If it was the database,
that's disk IO,
buffer lookups, query parsing, query
execution, etc. etc. etc.
And that's 50, about 50 milliseconds,
even with solid state drives, SSDs.
And every database connection
means a TCP handshake, a TLS
negotiation, cross AZ round trip.
That's about 5 milliseconds per each
iteration.
And that's just the protocol overhead
before your query even hits the database.
API economics.
Show me flights to Hawaii, probably gets
asked thousands of times every day.
Each uncashed request burns
inference costs. There's embedding
generation, there's LLM invocations.
You cash once and you amortize
the cost across the fleet.
Finally,
By definition, semantic search
and semantic lookups
mean cosine distance calculations
across these 1024, 1536,
3072 vector dimensions.
And you probably have millions and millions
of those vectors.
So caching those top K results
skips those heavy floating point cosine
distance operations entirely for those
repeat queries.
That's the kind of thing that we are looking for.
This is the speed layer that we're going to add to
our architecture.
Now, this is a great segue
on why caching is essential. Let's take a
little detour to the service side of things.
Amazon Elastic Cash is our fully managed
caching service.
It's Reddis OSS compatible,
MMCash T compatible, and Valy compatible.
Your application connects to a single
DNS endpoint
using standard REDDS or VALKI protocol.
Behind it is a managed proxy fleet
that handles connection multiplexing
across this distributed cluster.
And it gives you nice features such as consistent
hashing,
async replication across AZs,
sub-millisecond failover, and so on.
Of course, you throw in the services benefits, scaling
is automatic.
Now, this is the speed layer that eliminates
Flightly's bottleneck.
Let's see how it transforms the architecture.
So Elasticash's shared cluster architecture
serves data directly from memory,
regardless of which AZ the data lives in.
So it guarantees consistent microsecond
P99 latencies,
whether you are at 100 requests per second or
100,000 requests per second.
Now, just before reinvent, I think
about a week before reinvent or so,
we launched vector search for elastic
cash. And with it, durable
semantic caching.
With with Elastic cash, Valy, durable
semantic caching, we are actually hitting 90%
plus cache hit rates for
repeat queries.
What that means is 9 out of your
10 requests get served from memory.
Third is resilience.
Every shard maintains reed replicas
across availability zones.
When hardware fails, and during December
holiday traffic,
there are high chances that hardware might
fail, Elastic cache automatically
detects and promotes a reed replica to become
the new writer.
And of course, holiday traffic is inherently
unpredictable.
Spring breaks might spike 15 times
over a normal February baseline.
So elastic ash can monitor that and
provision additional shards as needed
to accommodate that growth.
Now we've solved speed, we are getting sub-millisecond
responses.
There's another component to this. Now we need
intelligence.
Your users aren't asking,
select start from destinations where
activities like beach.
They're asking, where can I surf and party.
And they don't repeat exact queries.
It's the intention.
It's they express intent
about those queries.
So, all of this relates to something called
semantic search.
So, let's see how semantic search actually works.
You start with your domain knowledge.
This would be travel guides, hotel descriptions,
visa policies, etc.
For Flightly, it's all in Auroraustress.
You break this corpus into bite-sized
chunks.
And then you feed this data through an embedding
model. Your text
in those documents becomes
multi-dimensional vectors,
and each dimension captures semantic
features, so similar concepts like
beach and coast clustered
together. Dissimilar
concepts will stay apart.
In practice, Miami's embeddings
will look something like this, pristine beaches
plus world-class clubs
across, let's say, those 1024 dimensions.
At Bali's encoding represents
tropical surf beaches plus wellness
spas.
Both contain beach components, mind
you. But then Miami
leans towards this urban and nightlife
theme, whereas Bali leans
more towards spiritual and wellness themes.
These embeddings get stored in a vector database.
Aurora Bres has PG vector, just
a show of hands who's heard of PG Vector.
OK, quite a lot of you, good.
So, PG vector for those uninitiated
is an extension in Postress
for storing and querying vector embeddings.
And this enables that semantic lookup, semantic
search. On
the other side, now, when your user comes and
asks this question, where,
where can I surf and party?
That query it's the same embedding model.
And gets converted into a 1024
dimensional vector, for example.
Now we run semantic search against
Aurora with PG vector.
This is what the query looks like. It's,
you never see it, the model handle
handles it behind the scenes.
What you do see are top matches,
Miami and Bali, ranked
ranked by a similarity score.
Now this is the intelligence layer. So
we had speed, now we added the intelligence layer.
This is how Flightly also moves
beyond a simple keyword match
to understanding true user intent.
Now, while this slide focuses
purely on semantic search,
using vector embeddings.
Traditional keyword based
full text search cannot be overlooked.
So Posters does have
a fully featured sort of full text search component
as well.
And in practice,
many of these search systems combine
both,
a technique which we call hybrid search.
Now, here, we are centered on semantic search,
but if you, you are interested, there is
also a session
tomorrow on hybrid search,
409.
Now, a quick detour to the service side.
Now, AWS offers several managed
databases with native vector search, and we
keep adding more and more databases
to this, uh, sort of whole
environment and ecosystem.
RDS for Postress supports vector search, so
does Postress, DocumentDB, OpenSearch,
etc.
Well, Flightly chose Arapustras
since their data already lived there. It was an easy choice.
Now in the aura surves architecture,
flight surge is usually very spiky, it
depends on seasonality.
Flash sales, etc. The way the architecture
works is again, you have this decoupled
compute and storage layer.
And with Aurora capacity units,
you can control the level of provisioning
required for scaling up or scaling down.
Now, Aurora IO optimize, which is
a storage configuration,
handles this IO intensive vector
search, plus your regular transactional
search, which is
bookings, payments, etc.
And there is no performance degradation because
of a little bit of better techniques that we
do with DI optimized configuration,
plus it gives you the added benefit of
predictable costs.
Data locality is a big win.
So vector embeddings live
in the same Postress tables as
your transactional data. This is your booking and
customer profiles.
No external database needed,
no ETL pipelines to set up, no migration
risks, and so on.
Finally, there is the global reach uh
perspective. So a global database
replicates across region with
subsecond replication lag.
A user in Tokyo gets served
from the Asia Pacific replica,
a user in London gets the EU replica.
Global data, local read performance.
All right. Now we have sort of the
complete architecture, right? So Elasticash
provides this sub-millisecond performance
for cached data.
Aurora is our durable sort of semantic intelligence
layer through PG Vector.
Let's see how these two integrate together.
We'll start with the foundational architecture and
add in layer and sophistication as we go.
Step one is simple Q&A. This is the baseline
pattern. I ask, can
you book flights from Vegas to Hawaii?
The query routes directly to Bedrock.
There's no preprocessing. There's no context
assembly,
just raw user input.
The LLM comes back with a response
using only its pre-trained knowledge, and
this is typically very generic. There
is no personalization here, nothing
particular to me as a user.
Now, here's the architectural challenge.
By definition, LLMs are stateless.
They don't remember anything.
So, they don't maintain any kind of a session
state or continuity between interactions.
The moment I close this chat,
conversation history is gone.
So there is, we need a
way for the chatbot to remember.
So let's add conversational memory
using elastic ash.
Step 2 is adding that conversation
history or chat history.
Now elastic ashes are layered to
store that conversation history.
So when this query arrives, which is a follow-up,
I'm not asking my previous question.
It's, what about hotels there?
It's assumed that elastic ash has now
the previous context,
and it can supply that context to my
prompt, which will again give me a
tailored response.
This is the shift. So we have now transformed
from stateless API calls into
stateless conversations.
Sorry, stateful conversations.
And elastic cache provides this
persistent session memory.
But notice, the responses here
are still fairly generic. There's no
personalization here just yet.
So step 3 is adding that personalization
layer. Now we are evolving
a little bit beyond the basic conversation
history. I ask another follow up,
recommend activities for my family.
Now elastic ash's role in this case expands.
We are now caching user profile data.
This will be hashes containing
family composition.
So I have two kids, ages 4 and 8,
activity preferences like outdoor adventures,
budget constraints like a $300 max.
Now, when this query arrives,
using elastic asset get all,
you can retrieve the complete preference hash
and inject it into the prompt.
The LLM will now generate a very tailored
response based on my
personalized information.
Activities appropriate for ages 4
to 8, aligned with outdoor adventures.
At this stage,
we are not just remembering,
we are enriching context with persistent
user attributes. It knows
information about me,
my family, and so on.
So elastic cash in this use case
provides both ephemeral session memory
and it provides the durable preference
storage.
This is the shift
from
remembering to understanding.
Now we are on to the final stage. So this
is contextual intelligence, also called retrieval
augmented generation.
I ask,
cheapest flight options for next month.
That's it. Aurora
postre enters the picture.
The application generates an embedding, executes
a semantic search against the flight model,
routes matching cheapest options
filtered by whatever date range that I
provide, joined with real-time
pricing to give me a very tailored
response. This
is rag in action.
We are now using elastic cache for
that sub-millisecond session state and
preference lookup.
But we are also using Aurora for
grounding the data
in our domain knowledge through semantic search.
Together they are providing this fast, personalized
and accurate customer experience.
So far, in 4 steps, we've built
a sophisticated, pretty sophisticated
conversational system.
It has memory,
it has chat history, it has personalization,
and it has contextual intelligence.
But remember,
we are still at the stage of a chatbot.
What if we could go beyond simple
Q&A?
What if it could go beyond just giving us
information about hotels availability,
flight availability,
go one step further and start booking
those for us.
That's the shift to agentic AI,
from answering questions to taking actions.
Before we get into the Asiatic layer and the architecture,
let's see how we got there. It's important to keep
this perspective in mind.
Before we knew it, 2 years ago, we
started with G AI chatbots.
Singleton,
rule-based,
constant human oversight.
Then came in Gen AI agents,
goal-driven systems that plan, reason,
and use tools.
A booking agent will go and search flights,
compare prices, execute workflows,
but still single domain.
Now we are stepping into the era of agentic
AI. Multi-agent systems
where specialized agents coordinate
very nicely,
your booking, your customer service agent, your
recommendation agent,
all communicating, delegating with minimal
oversight.
This is what we are building for Flightly.
Let's look at the architecture.
So, same travel question as before.
The agent retrieves cached context
in this case from Valy,
all in parallel, remember, so educate
all for user profile, L range for
conversation history, gets for session
state, sub-millisecond retrievals,
super quickly you assemble your
complete user context.
Simultaneously,
we are doing a semantic search against Aurora.
Query vectorization, similarity search, this
will be typically in two digit milliseconds.
User personalization from Valy,
domain knowledge from Aurora.
Now is where it gets interesting.
Tool invocation through
another concept called model context
protocol. So MCP
provides a standardized interface for
LLMs
to communicate with various services,
things such as APIs, data
databases, what have you.
The agent can also call external
APIs, things such as weather forecasts,
travel advisories, FAA regulations, etc.
So the result of all of this becomes
a super personalized, actionable
response. The agent asks
if you would like to book or explore other options.
This is promising,
but how do we actually implement this?
This is where Strand's Agents comes
in. It's an open source SDK
for building AI agents.
Lightweight, model agnostic,
supports Bedrock natively,
but it also goes beyond and has
integrations with OpenAI,
Anthropic, Olama, etc.
It handles this multi-agent orchestration,
provides native MCP tool support
with over 85 tools available.
And you can also integrate your existing
APIs with custom tools. We'll look at
a few examples later.
Let's look at the code.
So, building an agent with strands is
relatively straightforward. You have certain primitives
and you just have to implement those.
First, you import the core primitives
and configure your LLM.
In this case, we are using cloudsonne 4 on
Bedrock. Second, you
create the agent. It's as simple as that, one
line of code. That's
it. So, now you have a
functional AI agent.
But it's super limited, right? It can only
do simple Q&A.
Doesn't have any capabilities just yet.
So let's add capabilities.
Now we start defining the system prompt.
Remember, this is the personality of the agent.
Flight lease personality, domain expertise,
behavioral constraints, all go into the system
prompt. Your flight
lead, a travel assistant specializing
in flight booking and travel itineraries,
provide clear, concise, and professional
responses with helpful options and pricing.
So if a query comes in,
Something like
flights from Vegas to Hawaii,
the agent responds in character.
It'll have a travel domain focus,
it'll use a professional tone,
give you actionable options with the pricing.
But remember, agents can also
take actions. This is still a simple Q&A.
So let's add some tools, which is
the ability to act.
So, the fastest way to
give your agent access to the Aurora
Pore database is via
the Aurapustress MCP server, which becomes
a tool for the agent.
With the Eurostress MCP server, you connect
directly via standard connection parameters, the
ones that you're already used to.
So your host name,
your database credentials, there is
no custom tool implementation.
You are not writing any handwritten SQL wrappers.
The benefit is there is no maintenance
overhead.
Anytime your schema evolves, you can just use
your standard credentials to connect.
Now, Strands provides a list
tool sync API
which you'll see on line number 16,
which discovers these tools automatically.
This could be your MCP servers, plus
your custom tools, APIs, databases,
etc. Now, here,
Aurora Postress as an MCP server
exposes a couple of tools.
Get Table Schema and Run query. Get Table
Schema is for schema Discovery, and
Run Query is for running SQL queries.
So in this case, when we import
our tool and then make the tool and vocation,
the call to the database is about 2 digit
milliseconds, which is typically
what you'll have with a direct connection as well.
But then, notice this line.
There is a persistent MCP connection.
There is zero overhead of reconnection.
Anytime in post-ress, you're trying to re-establish
a connection,
there is a lot of overhead.
There is TCP handshake, TLS
negotiation,
art, etc. etc.
So MCP eliminates this whole bottleneck
and uses a persistent connection to
the database.
The other benefit is, of course, you get
to directly sort of uh you don't have to
write your own SQL query.
If you don't know SQL, your agent handles
that for you.
All right.
But your MCV servers can actually go
beyond these databases too.
Things, remember we talked about weather APIs?
So in this example, let's add a weather API.
Same pattern,
now for weather.
There is a special sort of symbol that we
use, the MCP tool decorator, which
you'll see. This defines
a function calling Open Weather API externally.
And this
code snippet actually exposes the weather data
API
as an MCP tool to the agent.
Our strands agent connects in the same way,
just like it did to Aurora.
But same protocol, different capability.
But here's the production challenge.
a million queries daily.
Many semantically similar,
whether in Hawaii, weather forecast,
Hawaii forecast,
temperature in Honolulu, etc. etc.
asked by a number of different users.
Each triggers an API call.
Expensive, slow, and unnecessary.
So we need some sort of intelligence that goes
beyond the standard MCP servers.
We need intelligence with tool caching
at the sort of the tool layer.
So, standard MCPs don't cut it. So
let's go a little bit beyond and add in
custom tools.
Now, I've mentioned tool a lot. Tools
are nothing but simply Python programs,
functions that give
business logic or execution logic to your agent.
Simply Python functions.
The tool decorator here gives you full
control over execution logic.
Here's an example.
So search flights takes origin,
destination,
optional date.
But then the dock string, which is the argument,
provides schema information the agent uses
to understand when and how to invoke it.
Here's where it gets powerful.
To logic defines that check
val key first.
If the thing exists in my cache,
return the results in under a milliseconds.
If it doesn't,
query Aurora.
There is a first time penalty. It'll hit the database,
yes,
but cash the subsequent results
to the, to the Valy layer. Again,
predictability is sort of maintaining there.
The key takeaway you'll notice here is
you want to use MCP for
things like schema discovery and non-critical
paths,
but you want to use custom tools when
you need capabilities beyond what
MCP provides or when performance
is critical.
This is the user output.
Anytime your
query doesn't hit the cache, it's gonna hit
the database. Again, two digit milliseconds,
about 85-ish.
But then the second time is the benefit. We
start getting those benefits right away with the
VALKY caching layer.
All right. So we've
built Flightly's complete architecture.
Now, let's extract some reusable patterns
that we'll use, which are basically blueprints
you can apply right away to your own applications.
Pattern one is context cache.
John asks, what about hotels
there? The agent
goes and queries Valy,
retrieves John's complete context, remember
the whole parallel operation,
chat history from the Wi Fi discussion, session
state, user preferences, etc.
etc.
Simultaneously, it runs a semantic search
with Aurora database.
In the end, all of this generates a
contextual, context-aware
response,
taking in John's preferences, etc. etc.
And this pattern is universally
applicable.
You can apply this to customer service, customer
service agents,
imagine maintaining ticket context,
virtual assistants, which will need to
remember preferences across sessions,
healthcare chatbots tracking patient
history. Any system where you think
conversation continuity matters,
you need that quick context retrieval, this
pattern will apply.
All right Pattern number 2 is
embedding cache.
This is where we accelerate the semantic search
by caching vector embeddings.
Pretty neat.
Think about users searching for things to do in
a new place.
These are almost always
short keyword-based lookups.
And chances are a lot of those users
are asking the same repeat questions all the
time. If I go to Japan, iconic
temples in Kyoto,
best food in Tokyo, etc. etc.
The first encounter, of course, is going
to be to the database.
And there's this whole embedding pipeline that you have to go
through, typically completes in about like
less than 200 milliseconds.
But then the subsequent
retrieval is through the caching layer,
which is where we get the advantage.
And given that these are surveillance services,
both of them can scale in place,
up or down, in or out.
Now pattern 3 is interesting. This is the durable
semantic caching by Elastic Ash.
So your data sources
come as natural to your embedding model
like before, this is the whole pipeline.
But a lot of the times, remember I said
people phrase things differently. They won't
be asking the same questions.
What are the best beach destinations in Hawaii?
Can you recommend beach resorts in Hawaii?
Yada yada yada, and so on and so forth.
Now, without semantic caching,
this goes through this entire pipeline
to get to the response.
Now, there is, of course,
LLM invocations,
there is embedding generation, there's a lot
that's going on.
And there is latency plus cost.
With semantic caching, what happens is you define
the similarity threshold,
and beyond that threshold, anytime
you have reached that threshold,
All of the questions which are similar get
clubbed into sort of a group,
and then you, the responses
get returned from the cache.
So you're caching both the similarity
plus the LLM responses
in your Valy layer.
And what happens is, by doing so,
you skip the entire pipeline
generation process.
And you're just going to the cache and retrieving
results.
Zero LLM cost,
no latency,
and sub-millisecond performance.
All right. So, uh, there
is, there was actually a deep dive session
on semantic caching. It was on Monday.
So I highly recommend uh watching the recording
on YouTube,
451.
This goes much deeper into semantic caching.
All right. This is how it looks like in
action. Green is good, red is bad.
With semantic caching on the left,
questions 1 through 4, we get instant
responses from Valy.
This is what we want
smooth, great performance, keeps users
engaged.
More importantly,
bookings complete on time.
Without,
same question triggers the full LLM
inference every single time.
What's worse is your users notice
these delays, and then they start abandoning
conversations mid-booking.
Pattern 4 is interesting. This is where we
get into a little bit of production architectures,
tiered memory management.
User says,
book family flights there, avoid
that airline.
Referencing maybe context from earlier, maybe
previous sessions, etc.
The agent passes messages
to VALKY for
short-term memory in this case.
We'll see it go through.
And then,
VALLKY, in this case, you'll notice
it stores things like chat messages, which
is your conversation history,
session state,
checkpoint. These are typically workflow checkpoints
if your agent is going through
certain ATL pipelines,
jobs,
or just a,
just a basic conversation.
You can define checkpoints so it can pick up
where it left off, similar to database checkpoints.
All of that can be cached and stored in
VALKY. Now,
the beauty is, you can
actually have this intelligence behind the
scenes.
Your lambda
asynchronously extracts the
short-term
nuggets of memory, so your, all
your conversation history, session state,
checkpoints, etc.
And push it out to Aurora as
your long-term storage.
Within Aurora,
with PG vector, the benefit that you get
is you can do things like episodic recall.
PG vector has
relatively every past
history stored as a long-term,
sort of a with a session ID memory
ID, the whole interaction.
And what you can do
is rebuild that entire conversation
looking at that long-term tiered storage.
This will be for this use case, things
like this user prefers aisle
seats
or window seats.
They have a budget, a strong budget of maybe $300
and less.
These are the things which will be persisted in the long term
storage, which can be looked upon across
devices, across channels every single
time. And of
course, you also have the MCPs thrown in. So,
and within the MCPs you can do things
like you can extract these memory modules,
you can list these memory events sequentially,
serially,
you can retrieve these memory records, rebuild
it, etc. A lot of things that
you can do with the agent.
So, this is sort of a
hot or short-term and long-term memory
separation.
Where it gets really interesting is this
sort of a tiered shared memory architecture
with multi-agent workflows, which is what
we are building for lightly.
So add travel insurance
before you book my flight.
Use the email from our support conversation.
This is sort of a stateful multi-agent workflow
where your shared memory
state is stored
in between Elasticash and Aurora
Press
for the agent to do sort of seamless handoff.
So Lotus,
you have an orchestrator, in this case, Flightly's
orchestrator.
It has 3 specialized agents. You have
your support agent, you have your booking agent, you have your
payment agent.
All of these
share memory
in both of these layers, your long-term storage
as well as your short-term memory.
Behind the scenes, we are still doing the same thing.
We are extracting the short-term memory from
elastic ash,
persisting it to Aurora.
And in this way, you're basically sharing the
state and the workflow will be your first,
your support agent queries Aurora semantically.
It will find last week's support
conversation, extract the email.
Booking agent will go and search flights,
reserve them and writes this confirmed
booking state to Valy, that's
your checkpoint.
Payment agent will go and read this
confirmed booking state and add the
insurance and then process the payment.
So, all of this is orchestrated through
a common memory layer.
There is no context drop off,
there is no sort of
continuity lost between agent handoffs,
and states are synchronized in
real time between the two of them.
All right, We've looked at
5 different patterns. We've looked at different steps
in building this conversational AI system.
Now the critical question.
How do we scale this to production?
a million daily queries,
high availability, cost optimization,
security. So far, our
agents are running locally on our laptops.
Your MCP server, a Raposters MCP
server, is running as an STDIO
local Python subprocess on your laptop.
What if your laptop crashes?
What happens mid-transaction? You lose the transaction,
obviously, that's a no go.
How do we scale this?
So, this is where Bedrock Agent Core
comes in. Just to show our fans who's
not heard of Agent Core.
Anyone? Everyone's heard,
one person hasn't heard of Agent Core, yes.
So Agent Core is an agent tech platform
to build,
run, and deploy agents securely
at scale.
Think about how we run Postress
on self-managed servers versus
Aurora Postress as a fully managed server.
Agent Core is your fully managed capability
to run agents.
It has a lot of components to it, we won't go
too deep into it.
There's a lot of sessions around for Agent Core,
but at a very high level,
runtime provides your local agents
and environment to run at scale on
the cloud. You're not running agents locally
anymore. The beauty about this framework
is, you're not restricted to just
bedrock models. You can use OpenAI,
you can use Anthropic, you can use Gemini,
it doesn't matter.
Plus, you can bring your own agentic frameworks,
such as crew uh Crew AI, Autogen,
Lang chain, Landgraf,
what have you.
Agent core identity gives you that secure
sort of identity and access management for your agents,
which is super critical in production.
Agent code gateway gives you
sort of a, a gateway to your MCP
servers, your custom tools, your lambda
functions, your open API schemas,
your existing tooling or business logic
gets fronted by agent code gateway,
and it gives you that routing layer to
sort of make it more seamless
for your existing application.
There are a couple of other tools like uh browser
and code interpreter. Browser is, if
you're familiar with computer use for
cloud, you give your agent access to your
computer, which you should not, to do
things.
Browser is used for that.
Code interpreter is more of a sandboxed code
execution environment.
But then you also have some other nicer features
like agent core memory, which also offers
out of the box, short-term and long-term memory modules.
And to wrap all this around sort of good
guardrails and tracing of the agent
actions,
you have the agent core observability layer
as well. So,
remember my Friday frustration?
Same journey,
completely rebuilt.
In this case, Valy caches the
frequently asked questions,
baggage policies, booking templates,
uh, email templates, and it returns
these results in microseconds.
Aurora with PG Vector handles the route
information, looking up seat preferences,
long-term memory, semantic search,
all in two digit milliseconds.
9 out of 10 customers stay,
60% cost savings,
performance that truly scales.
And with that, Flightly is ready
for Hawaii,
and so are you.
With that, thank you for your time, Mohalo.
I do have a couple of resources to share.
And if you do have questions, uh, let's
take them outside.
But please do remember to complete the session survey.
And yes, thank you for attending. Enjoy the rest
of treatment.